let's talk a little bit about arteries
and veins and the roles they play in the
circulatory system so I want you to
pause this video and first think to
yourself do you have a sense of what
arteries and veins are well one idea
behind arteries and veins are that well
in most of these drawings arteries are
drawn in red and I even made the artery
word here in red and veins are drawn in
blue and so maybe that represents how
much oxygen they have and so one
possible explanation is that arteries
carry oxygenated blood oxygenated
oxygenated blood while veins carry
deoxygenated blood so blood that has
less oxygen now now this is actually
incorrect it is many times the case that
arteries are the ones carrying
oxygenated blood and veins are carrying
the deoxygenated blood but as we will
see this is not always the case and
since we're already talking about
oxygenated blood and deoxygenated blood
and the colors red and blue it's worth
addressing another misconception many
times it is said that deoxygenated blood
looks blue and the reason why people
believe that is if you look at your
wrists and you're able to see some of
the vessels in there you will see some
blue vessels and those or they at least
look blue when you're looking from the
outside of your skin and those indeed
are veins and so that's where the
misconception has come from that veins
which when your arm are carrying
deoxygenated blood that that
deoxygenated blood is blue it turns out
that it is not blue it is just a deeper
red and the reason why the veins look
blue is because of the optics of light
going through your skin and then seeing
the outside of the veins and then
reflecting back that is not the color of
the actual blood so so far I have not
given you a clear definition of what
arteries versus veins are a better
definition so let me cross these two out
are that arteries carry blood away from
the heart away from the heart and veins
carry blood towards the heart two words
the heart and I can get a zoomed in
image of the heart right here and that
will make it a little bit clearer and
you can also see or we're about to see
why this first definition or this first
distinction between arteries and veins
does not always hold so let's just
imagine some blood that is being pumped
away from the heart so right when it
gets pumped away from the heart it'll be
right over here it gets pumped through
the aorta and you can see the aorta
branches so some blood can go can go up
towards your head and if it didn't you
would pass out and die and then a lot of
the blood goes down towards the rest of
your body and that indeed is the most
oxygenated blood and so it'll flow
through your body and these arteries
will keep branching and branching into
smaller vessels all the way until they
form these very small branches and it's
that place especially where they will
lose a lot of their oxygen to the fluid
and the cells around them and then the
blood is less oxygenated and then even
though deoxygenated blood is not blue it
often gets depicted as blue in a lot of
diagrams so I will do the same and then
these vessels start building into your
veins and these really small vessels
that really bridge between arteries and
veins where a lot of the gas and
nutrient exchange occurs these are
called capillaries and so after going
through the capillaries the blood will
then come back to the heart and now it's
coming towards the heart through the
veins it comes into the right atrium
then the right ventricle then that gets
pumped towards the lungs and this is the
exception to the first incorrect
definition of arteries and veins that we
looked at this right over here is an
artery even though it's carrying less
oxygenated or deoxygenated blood it's an
artery because it's carrying blood away
from the heart but in this case it's not
carrying it to the rest of the body it
is carrying it to the lungs that is why
it is called the pulmonary artery even
those carrying Lex
oxygenated blood and so that it goes to
the lungs and then in the lungs there's
more gas exchange that occurs the blood
gets oxygenated and then it comes back
to the heart and so it comes back to the
heart in these vessels right over here
and that even though these are carrying
highly oxygenated blood these are
considered veins because they're
carrying blood towards the heart so
these are pulmonary pulmonary veins and
then the cycle starts again the
pulmonary veins bring that oxygenated
blood into the left atrium and the left
ventricle and then that pumps it to the
rest of the body to the aorta for your
systemic circulation
you have your pulmonary circulation
which circulates the blood to through
and from the lungs and you have your
systemic circulation which takes the
blood to and from the rest of the body
so now that we have this main
distinction between arteries and veins
what are some other interesting things
that we know about it well one thing to
keep in mind is that since arteries are
being pumped directly by the heart
towards the rest of the body they have
high pressure I'll write that in caps
high high pressure and so if you were to
have an accident of some time but you
would do not want to have and you were
to accidentally cut an artery because of
that high pressure it would actually
spurt spurt blood a lot more than if you
were to cut a vein and most of the times
where you get a cut you're really just
cutting capillaries like if you were to
prick your finger it's usually a series
of capillaries that get cut and that's
why the blood would come out very very
slowly
now if arteries are high pressure veins
are low pressure low low pressure and
one way to think about it is the
arteries the blood is being pumped
directly by the heart but then once it
goes through the capillaries and comes
back through the veins it's kind of
sluggishly making its way back to the
heart it's not being directly pumped and
that's why in veins because you don't
have that high pressure to bring
everything back to the heart you have
these valves that make sure that for the
most part the blood is going
in one direction and I'm gonna draw the
blood in red in the veins just so that
we don't keep going with that
misconception that blood in the veins is
blue somehow now related to the fact
that the blood in the arteries is under
higher pressure in order to transport a
fixed volume of blood in a certain
amount of time you need less volume and
so that's why arteries are low volume
and on the other hand veins are high
volume and to appreciate the difference
the blood volume in arteries are only
approximately 15% of the entire blood
volume in your body while the blood
volume in veins are closer to 65%
approximately 65% and if you're
wondering where the rest of the blood is
about 5% is in capillaries 5% is in your
heart and about 10% is in your lungs so
I will leave you there the big takeaway
arteries are the vessels that take blood
away from the heart veins are the
vessels that take blood towards the
heart